I just need you guys to know we were dancing to the opening.
Okay, wait, you don't like it when you see my wings.
It's a little freaky.
Yeah, that's...
We were dancing to the opening, so that's why it took us so long, guys.
We were busy dancing to the opening.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Sorry, we were...
For like 15 minutes.
Yeah, for like 15...
Wait, wait, get closer.
Look how fucking huge she is compared to me.
Okay, but when I came in, you were so...
Okay, that's true, that's true.
I was like...
I was like this.
Holy crap.
Oh my god.
Damn.
That's terrifying.
This is IRL height difference right there.
Actually, you should be a little bit shorter.
You are...
No, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a dramatization.
I feel like I'm in danger.
Good.
Don't make me put you in the box.
I'll put you in the box.
One at a time.
Why does my vision go black when I'm close to the box?
Yeah, it's programmed so you can't see anything if you're in the box.
Oh my god!
It's my special box.
I think I'm addicted.
I'm addicted to the special box.
Yeah.
How's the volume, guys?
How's the volume, chat?
So far.
Let me be tiny again.
I feel too big in this form.
Be tiny so I can squish you.
I can kick you in the shins.
I can punch you in the face.
I can kick you in the face.
Oh wait, I'm like perfect.
I'm like perfect.
Why are you doing that?
Why are you poking my belly button?
Your arms are too short.
You can't even raise them up.
I don't need to raise them up.
Raise me up.
You jump really high.
Hey guys, today is not a special day.
It's just a normal day.
It's a normal day.
It's a normal day, guys.
We do have an announcement together.
But other than that, it's just a normal day.
Huge shout out to Mint.
Because like, literally I asked her yesterday if she could do this.
And she...
And I was just like, okay.
And then she uploaded her video.
And then she posted it on her VRChat model.
Like, what was it?
An hour before?
10 minutes ago.
10 minutes ago!
Yeah, yeah.
She got it.
Got it under 10 minutes.
We had to message VRChat staff and be like, we don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
VRChat staff, help us.
You know what?
The worst part is I finally got it.
Yeah.
It was like, maybe a minute after, or a minute before they uploaded it for me.
Oh, what?
So I have a backup.
Oh, so that's good.
That's good.
You have a backup.
But they were so helpful.
Thank you, VRChat team.
They gave us free stuff.
We have like, membership now.
What was it called though?
They gave us like, VR Plus.
Yeah, we got VR Plus!
Yay!
We love free stuff.
VRChat Plus.
I don't know what we can do with it, but like, it's free, so that's all that matters.
You know?
Free stuff!
Yay!
I'm actually jumping.
No, it doesn't track it!
I need to raise you up a little bit.
Is it voices?
I'm gonna raise you up a little bit higher.
75%.
Oh yeah, we wanna take you to Chickentopia.
We're gonna be exploring VRChat worlds.
Chickentopia!
Yeah, we don't have to worry about copyright.
I know you took them to like, the snake place.
Metal Gear Solid places.
Oh yeah, I took them to Metal Gear Solid last time.
Yeah, wait, the snake place.
The snake place.
Yeah, the snake place!
There's like, snakes in the water.
Wait, you had it open, right?
Chickentopia?
Yeah, I can put that up for us.
Yeah, I saw it on my Twitter For You page.
It was like, basically we raise chickens and we put them in a box and then we send them up into the air.
To die, I guess.
Chicken heaven?
Yeah, where they go to chicken heaven!
They're gonna go to chicken heaven!
Like, all dogs go to heaven!
Oh!
That's...
Okay.
What do you mean?
Drop a portal.
There ya'll!
Yay!
See ya there!
Woo!
Sorry, I have to like...
Technical difficulties, but here we go!
Here we go!
For real!
Yay!
This is a normal day!
Just a normal streaming day!
Oh, I need to be a bit louder.
Okay.
Let me double check.
Whoa!
That's my face!
Is that my face?
Oh, that is!
Okay, let me put myself a little louder.
Okay.
Have you ever been here before?
Whoa!
No, I haven't.
Looks real- Whoa!
This looks amazing!
It looks crazy!
Yeah!
Okay, you guys can't see it.
There's a lot of birds!
Oh my god!
Guys, look!
Oh, the lighting changes everything!
Wait, that's so cool!
Whoa!
Okay, let me get my...
There's birds everywhere!
Where's the camera?
It's right in front of you!
Oh, it is?
I'm literally holding it!
No, no, not that one!
The pin one!
Okay, anchor.
Oh, I forgot!
You have to like...
Put like this thing here.
The local.
You are so close!
I wanna take a screenshot!
Stop!
Stop taking screenshots!
No!
There we are.
Oh my god, look at that!
Look, oh my god!
Look at the shading on this!
Oh my god.
Yeah.
I know, it's beautiful!
Yeah, it's so crazy!
Okay, let's see.
Behavior.
Don't look at me.
Okay, don't...
Maybe?
I can't...
Mint, I'm not very good at this.
I'm not...
You have done behavior change so many times!
They keep...
They keep updating it!
It's not my fault!
Okay, hold on.
I'm opening up stream camera.
What are you looking for?
What's the problem?
I don't know.
What's the perfect, you know, angle?
The perfect camera angle?
I always...
I put it behind me.
I put it behind me and then they get to like watch me.
Oh!
See?
You're so smart.
It's like they're traveling with us.
Yeah!
It's like POV.
You know like that one with the girl and then she holds her hands out like this?
And then you're like holding her hand and you're like, Yeah, let's go travel.
Like that.
You remember that YouTube video?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
Are you gonna hold the dragoon's hands?
Yeah, that's where they'll get cooties.
Okay, I think you need to let it...
Okay, so...
You need to like...
There's like...
It's too close.
All I see is your head.
Okay.
Alright.
Hold my hand!
Get the cooties!
And now you can't even see me!
Yay!
We did it!
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I put it local after that.
And then... Yeah!
We did it, guys.
We did it.
We're so good at this.
Let's go get some chicken!
Oh my gosh, wait.
Wait.
Where's the chicken?
Right here.
Over here!
Oh my god!
Hey!
Wait.
I need to fix the camera.
Where did the camera go?
Oh, there!
Why is the camera over there?
Oh my god!
What?
Fuck!
Okay, let me put the camera like...
Oh my god!
There's a flying bitch!
Where is she going?
Where is she...
Oh my god!
Okay.
What the fuck?
Did you see that?
Oh my god, that was crazy.
That was crazy.
Okay, I need to figure...
I'm gonna burn it!
Wooo!
It's the simple things.
I think I'm gonna throw up.
Where did the camera go?
I lost the camera!
It's right here!
Oh, it is!
Hello guys.
Do you guys have...
You're the one who made this!
You're my transparent!
I think the...
The like fish eye lens on it.
I'm a little special.
It's kinda crazy.
There's a fish eye lens on it?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh my god.
I lost it again.
Oh, there it is!
I see it!
It's right...
Oh my god!
It's so hard to see it!
It's right there!
It's so hard!
It's so hot!
Oh, there's old!
Old timey.
We're in the old time west.
Oh my god.
Wait, they have new...
They have like new filters and everything.
Oh, I see it in sepia.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah, like...
The speed's always been there.
I remember the speed.
But like...
They have the...
I know like the old one was new.
I know like the...
This was new.
What?
Do you wanna say that again?
The old one?
It's literally titled old!
OOOHHHH!
Whoa!
There's a...
There's a trippy...
There's a trippy filter.
Have you seen the trippy filter?
There is?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Your head!
We're like a little...
We're like kids at the carnival.
With the wall of hair.
We're like...
We're already...
And then there's...
Oh, there's the sparkle.
I don't like the sparkle as much though.
I think the trippy one was my favorite.
Okay guys, I figured it out.
I figured out how to use the camera.
Guys, okay.
She figured it out.
I figured it out.
Wait, why does it follow me?
Like in the back.
It doesn't follow me in the back.
What do you mean?
Like when I move the camera...
Oh wait, no.
I have to move my...
myself.
And then...
Wait, no?
Is the camera...
Are you okay?
Yeah, okay.
So if I look at this way, do you see my back?
Uh...
Uh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
I figured it out!
Alright, we did it guys.
Okay.
Now we can check out the chickens.
Yeah, we did it guys.
We can check out the chickens.
Alright, here's...
Oh, it's on your front again, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Alright.
Why is the...
Wait, so we take a chicken?
Yeah, we take a chicken.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
We put it in a box?
Oh my god.
And then if...
What if I'm also in the box?
Wait, send me out!
And then we press the button.
We press the...
We press this.
Okay.
Sell it.
Why are we selling the...
VINCE!
Holy shit!
Wait, I wanna get a chicken.
Alright, dragons.
I'm gonna grab you.
This is you.
We're gonna sell you.
We're gonna sell you dragons.
We're off to...
Off to heaven you go!
Off to heaven!
You're getting...
You're getting... getting into heaven!
Oh my god.
I can't get on the box.
I can't...
No!
I have a special chicken buck.
Alright, can you put this in?
There you go.
Down you go.
Goodbye.
Goodbye everybody!
Oh my god.
I'm so far out.
Holy...
Oh my god.
Yeah, you can...
You can spend more money to get more chickens.
Get more dragons.
Oh!
Wait, I have a...
Wait.
Wait, how did you get the money?
I earned it.
Later!
Look at her go.
There is my camera.
I'm paying... I'm paying you.
Oh, I got it.
No no no no.
Come on.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh my god.
It says don't forget to feed the chickens.
Do we...
Do we need to feed them?
No we don't.
I don't know.
I think we have to.
Did you get it?
Redeem!
Click it.
Hold on I have to push the...
I'm trying!
I think we're too short for this.
You gotta be this height.
I got him!
What is this?
Oh that's to feed the chickens!
It's an apple!
Wait but where are the chickens?
Wait don't get...
Wait we got rid of our chickens.
We got rid of all our chickens.
Wait I think...
I think we were supposed to breed the two chickens we have.
I think we were supposed to...
We...
We saw them.
We know what happened.
I thought...
Ellie didn't stand.
I thought we had more chickens.
I thought...
I thought it would give us chickens.
I didn't realize we have to breed them.
We can go find more.
There's probably a ton of chickens out there.
Oh no.
I don't...
Barrel chickens.
I don't see any chickens around.
Here let's go on the bus.
Let's go on the bus.
Okay.
Yeah.
The bus.
Wait.
What?
There's a chicken!
Oh!
It's a purple chicken!
Wait!
It came out of the apple!
Yeah!
Wait!
Is that where chickens come from?
Where's our camera so you can...
There it is.
Yeah I'm showing it.
I'm showing it.
Look!
A chicken came out of apples!
Guys every time you eat an apple you eat a chicken.
That's right vegetarians.
You are not a real vegetarian because you eat apples.
He died!
Oh!
Wait okay he's fine.
Oh no does he grow up?
He... if you drop him he smushes.
Watch.
Ugh!
Wait.
No.
Ugh!
Oh!
It made a sound!
What the fuck!
Like...
He gets really small, huh?
Yeah!
Can you like smush it with your hands?
I think I stepped on him earlier.
Oh see!
I smushed him.
Yeah you smush him.
Wait can we get another one?
Do we have more money?
Oh!
Yeah we have more money.
It made the sound.
Where'd the money go?
Yeah where's the money go?
Wait where'd the money go?
Where'd the money go?
There was the money.
You...
There was another money.
Where's the money?
Doki what'd you do?
What did I do?
Doki, Doki where's the money?
What do you mean?
All I do is send chickens out of there!
Oh!
All I do is send the chickens up in the air!
Doki where's the money?
I don't know!
I can't see you!
Did we fuck up?
Where's my money?
Did we fuck up the world?
Did we mess it up?
Oh I found it!
I found it!
Oh okay.
Alright.
Okay.
POV.
And redeem.
You are the machine that she redeems from.
Oh we're gonna get a mushroom monkey!
Oh!
I mean a monkey.
A monkey?
Oh god.
This is chicken-topia not mushroom-topia?
This is...
I thought it was bloons.
How many hours have you spent on bloons, Mint?
How many hours?
Oh god he's huge now!
Oh my god look!
Look he's big!
Oh my god!
He's so big!
Wait so does that mean we don't feed the chicken?
We just...
We just get...
More chickens?
We only get two?
No I think we feed them right?
Yeah we feed the mushroom to the chicken.
Yeah.
Wait where did it go?
Oh my god!
These are very toxic!
Alright guys I don't...
I think this chicken has a few medical issues.
Here chicken!
I think this chicken has medical issues.
Mint.
Eat!
It's on her head Mint.
It's like...
It has tumors.
Oh my god!
Gross!
It's on her changed.
I just want enough for her to eat.
Okay well that's more food for her.
It's okay I still love our son.
The chicken sounds!
Oh wait.
The chicken sounds.
There's an egg!
They made it for me!
We're compensate!
Gramp!
Their made an egg.
We're Grampons.
I'm gonna feed them lots.
I'm gonna feed them so much.
Come on.
More babies!
Oh my god!
What happened to the egg?
Oh, it's the yellow chicken!
Oh my god, the first thing it did was eat!
Wait, how did you feed it?
Oh my god, they're fighting!
They're fighting!
They're fighting?
Oh my god!
Don't fight!
They're your kind!
Wait, how did you get Caesar?
Come on!
Oh god!
Get some seeds!
Yes!
Eat!
Oh shit!
I smushed them!
It's okay, they're still alive.
It's okay, it's okay.
They like it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, they're still fine.
Come on!
Chicken sons!
Seed!
Where are the eggs?
Oh my god, he's getting really big.
Oh my god.
That guy's getting really big.
Wait, he is.
Oh my god, there's four eggs!
We're gonna be rich!
We have so many chickens!
I'm gonna feed them until they pop.
We've got giant chickens.
Get bigger chickens.
Oh my god.
We've got huge chickens.
Oh my god, she's going...
We've got the largest chickens in the world.
We've got the huge and giant chickens.
Guys, I think she's mad with power right now.
She's mad with power.
There's so many chickens.
Oh, there's so many.
There's so many.
Your entire body...
We'll never be able to feed the chickens again.
Your entire body is covered with chickens.
We'll never go hungry again!
We'll never go hungry!
We have all the chickens we can eat!
What are you talking about?
This is my army.
Your army.
I'm gonna feed them all.
And thus, the whiffs evolved into chickens.
They love me.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Can anybody see me?
I'm so hungry.
Do you see her?
Do you see...
It's okay!
She's in the pile of chickens!
Okay, I give up.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Look at that pink one.
I know.
Alright, who should we sell first?
This guy.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
What did you do?
I think you...
Can anybody see me?
I'm still here.
Wait, did you crash the server?
Did you crash the server?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Can anybody see me?
I'm still here.
Oh my god.
This guy.
Oh, it's repeating!
It's repeating!
Oh my god.
Can anybody see me?
I'm still here.
Oh my god.
This guy.
Oh, it's repeating, guys!
It's repeating!
Oh my god.
Can anybody see me?
It's repeating!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Can anybody see me?
I'm still here!
Oh, look at this guy.
Holy shit!
I'm in a loop!
I'm stuck in a loop!
Oh my god, I was stuck in a loop.
That was the craziest shit!
The crash!
Holy shit, that was a loop!
I think Mint fucking crashed the server!
I'm launching back up.
We were looping.
Oh my god.
We had too many chickens.
There were too many chickens!
Oh my god.
The chickenopolis apocalypse.
That was actually crazy.
I was not expecting the looping.
Oh, I put the volume in already.
Do you guys need it to be lowered even more?
Too many chickens.
I didn't realize there was a limit to how many chickens you can have.
I wonder if I can, like, get an invite.
Like, is she still in Chickentopia?
Is she still there?
Let's see...
Request.
Um...
Request invite.
I'm requesting invite right now.
She was too powerful.
The chickens were just too many.
There was just too many chickens.
That was actually crazy.
I can't believe there was an actual limit to how many chickens you can have.
Oh my god.
There was a chicken limit.
Okay, don't worry.
We're coming back.
We're coming back right now.
Worlds.
Uh...
We're going back to Chickentopia.
The voice.
What?
Don't worry.
It's a blackout.
I'm going back to the black screen because, like, I need to get in the world.
And then get the camera out.
I don't have the camera out yet.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
It got worse.
How did it get worse?
There's so many chickens.
Okay.
I'm trying.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm trying.
You don't see me yet.
Because I'm trying to figure out the...
But you're going to see how there's more chickens.
How is there more chickens?
What did you do?
I'm selling the chickens!
I'm selling them right now!
How is there more chickens?
I'm selling the chickens!
You crashed my server!
We're not making any more money!
I think we need to leave!
We're selling them!
We're selling all these chickens!
I think we broke the economy!
We broke the chicken economy!
What?
They can't even pay us!
We have too many chickens!
We don't even spend the rest of our money!
Why are you still selling?
Because we gotta get rid of these chickens!
You're the one that breeded them!
We have too many chickens!
Oh no!
I'm trying to heal you!
The great...
The great chicken crash!
I can't believe it!
You burst the chicken bubble!
How did you burst the chicken bubble?
I don't know.
I can't believe she didn't.
She burst the chicken economy.
They won't even...
I think we have to breed more chickens!
Wait, wait!
To get them to sell chickens!
Wait, just pay...
Oh my god, they're following!
They're just...
They're following you!
Holy shit!
It's because I'm their master!
I'm gonna squish all of them.
I'm big boys!
I love them!
Wait, wait, wait!
Toki!
Don't you understand?
I'm the big cock!
You're the big cock!
Yeah!
I rule them all!
I don't know.
It doesn't really like...
Um...
It's not very effective when I see you try to jump up and reach it.
We're gonna get a square chicken!
Oh my god, no!
That's an ice cube!
We're gonna get an ice chicken!
We're gonna get a snow chicken!
Wait, I heard like...
I heard fire chicken is weak ag...
Wait, I heard like ice chicken is weak against fire chicken.
I...
We need to get fire chicken.
We need to get fire chicken!
Oh my god, you're literally like the mom.
It's following you everywhere.
Oh my god!
Wait, we got a strawberry chicken!
Oh no, that's how I die.
Oh my god, the ice chicken!
Look, there's snow coming out of the ice chicken!
You're so cute!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry for squishing.
I'm so sorry.
Guys, look!
Look!
Look, there's snow coming out!
This one is mine.
We're good!
Are you good?
Are you sure?
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, look at the strawberry chicken!
Wait, is that a ghost chicken?
Oh my god!
I think it's a ghost chicken!
Wait!
Oh my god!
Guys, look!
We got a strawberry chicken too!
Look at him!
This is how I die.
Did you just eat the strawberry?
Gonna die, everybody.
They say you only live once.
YOLO.
YOLO!
Wait, where's the ghost chicken?
Where is it?
Look!
Wait, that's a wisp!
It's a wisp!
Guys!
I'm gonna eat the wisp.
I'm gonna eat the wisp!
You can't stop me!
It must hurt more!
Look at the wisp!
Guys, look, there's the wisp!
There he is!
Oh, there's you!
Yes!
Oh my god!
My precious son!
There's your son!
There he is!
He's so cute!
Oh my god, it jumped into your head!
Oh god, he's so cute!
Wait, do we have more?
Where's more?
Oh my god, that's not ours.
That's not ours.
What do you mean that's not ours?
Oh, what the hell is that?
Did you birth that one?
That guy's adopted.
There's no way!
I would never love this son!
He was throwing it away!
Wait!
They didn't even stop it!
Oh my god!
She instantly threw away the chicken!
He's still here!
Oh, okay.
Wait, where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh my god, that's not you!
Oh, there's too many!
Guys, this is the son that we don't own.
Whose son is this?
I don't know how we get blessed chickens!
This is not ours!
Who is this ugly son?
Is this a wisp?
Okay, look.
Look at the guy we just got.
What is he?
He's got glasses!
Show them to them!
He's cool!
Look, he has glasses!
Look!
I think this is yours.
I think it's mine.
He thinks after me.
Wait, this one looks like you!
Wait, what is this?
What the fuck?
How is this me?
It looks like you!
How?
It just has a...
It's you!
Oh yeah, the sun's yellow.
Is that also me?
This is literally what she thinks looks like me, guys.
This is here.
This guy right here.
Okay, I can't chat.
You say it looks like her too, right?
Wait, where did...
Oh my god!
The wisp grew up so big!
Look!
What did you feed him?
I can punch it.
Soothes!
You know, life force and stuff.
Ugh!
That's why I'm so tall.
I can punt it.
I think we just got a boob.
You just got a boob?
What?
Wait, this one is broken.
Wait, what do you mean?
What's wrong with it?
Look at it!
It's broken on top!
No, I think it's a flower.
It's a boob!
Is this a boob?
Will I get demonetized?
YouTube, is this a boob?
Is this a nipple?
Wait, wait, put it up against your chest!
Put it up against your chest!
Get over here!
Wait, get over here, man!
Put this against your chest and look at the camera.
Like this?
Yeah, yeah, and then move more to this.
Move more here.
Shhh!
No!
Wait, he's so cool!
Show it!
He's so cool!
Guys, this is it.
This is... You got a mohawk and everything!
We're just gonna be in Chickatopia forever.
We're gonna...
We can't stop making more chickens!
What the hell?
Okay, this one is an abomination.
Don't get me wrong.
This one is an abomination!
What the fuck?
Did a dog got in?
I don't know.
Who let the dogs in?
Who let the dogs out?
What's wrong with this one?
Is this a boob one?
Why do they look like this?
That's a boob one!
It has like a boob on top!
Guys, all you hear is boop, boop, boop, boop.
We have so many!
All you hear is boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop!
I'll lead them!
I'll lead them into a better future!
Come, my chickens!
We will be ready!
Oh my god!
Help!
Are you okay?
Oh my god!
Where are they going?
Where are the chickens going?
I don't know!
Look at them go!
Where are they going?
There they are!
There's the chickens!
The horde of chickens!
They're following Mint!
There they go!
Off to the distant lands!
Okay, now we can leave them here in a little more quiet.
Oh, that's true!
That's true!
I'll get some more!
Did you just abandon your chickens?
My chickens!
Did you just abandon the children?
Follow me, my chickens!
Yeah!
Follow me, chickens!
This way, chickens!
Goodbye, chickens!
Goodbye!
Wait, why aren't they coming?
Wait, are they my chickens?
Oh, they follow me?
Okay, chickens, come over here, chickens!
Come over here!
Wait, they stopped following me.
Your chickens are kind of stupid.
Yo, my chickens are smart.
They know what we're gonna do.
You're gonna get abandoned!
No!
Your chickens are stupid!
They were like, my mama loves me.
They know.
Yeah, I do!
I'm leading them to a greater place!
You're abandoning them!
No, they're here!
They're free!
That's not abandonment!
What will they eat?
Wait, wait, wait!
They're over there!
They're over here!
This one chicken...
That's following you.
You have two chickens behind you.
What the fuck?
I do.
I'm gonna throw them away.
Ah!
Get over here!
Oh my god!
Why can't you go further?
Get over there!
Be there with your...
Hey, it came back!
Be there with your sons!
With your friends!
Alright, there they are.
Now run!
Okay, okay.
Are they following?
Just run.
Where's the house?
Okay, nice.
Alright, nice.
Now we've reduced the chicken population.
That's good!
We did it!
But we still can't sell more.
We're sold out.
I think we maxed out the...
We must have maxed out the like...
available...
Chickens.
Yeah.
Here, I'll try selling one.
Come here.
Okay.
Bye!
No, he just falls through the bottom.
Oh!
They reject their chickens?
Is it cause they're...
Is it cause they're white?
And they need to be the special ones?
They don't take default chickens anymore?
Alright, boob chicken, we don't... Get rid of... Get rid of toast!
We're gonna get rid of toast!
Toast, come here!
Get away!
We never wanted you!
Get in there, toast!
Alright, we'll see.
Oh!
We want...
We wanted toast!
Yeah, we always wanted toast.
We lie about that.
Yeah, we're just testing...
Yeah.
We were just testing you!
We wanna see your commitment!
Yeah!
I wanna...
We've always loved toast.
Yeah, we love toast.
It's cause it has crust on it.
That's what makes it uglier.
There's crust on that toast.
Oh...
What are you doing?
I'm putting them in jail.
I don't wanna see that one anymore.
Oh yeah, by the way, you guys haven't seen him?
We think the dog, uh, got to the chickens.
Because what the fuck is wrong with him?
Like... What is wrong with this guy?
We might...
We might actually be like...
You know, scientists.
We created a new species.
The genetics worked.
It actually worked, guys.
Alright, I chose Chickentopia as your turn.
Oh...
Wait, I didn't know I was supposed to do the world!
Wait, do you wanna go check out the Fortnite bus?
Oh yeah, let's check out the Fortnite bus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fortnite bus!
Fortnite, we love Fortnite.
We love Fortnite.
This is the bus that took us through the whole new world.
Wait, this is so cute!
Oh, that's so...
Oh my gosh, they can't see it.
Guys, don't worry, camera.
I'm gonna figure this out.
Guys, I know you can only see the outside of the camera.
Come on in!
Wait, how do I bring it to me?
I'm shutting the doors!
Oh no, no, you're not gonna let them in!
They're not in yet!
It's too late!
No!
Guys, get in here!
Okay, I'll let them in.
I'll let them in.
Guys, get in here!
It's not my fault!
I don't know how to use the camera!
Okay, there we go.
Oh, look at it.
There's like...
Oh, maybe these are like supporters.
And stuff.
I'm the bus driver.
Say thank you to your bus driver, guys.
Whoa.
Thank you, bus driver.
You're barely... you're like phasing... just like a ghost, you're phasing through the...
the...
That's peak performance.
That's how you drive.
That's lore.
Immersion.
Oh god!
There's an accident!
Oh, we're gonna go over!
Not the chickens!
Think of the chickens!
I'm dead now.
You're already dead.
Wait, is that how you died?
Is that your ghost lore?
You died from the Fortnite bus?
Died in the Fortnite bus?
That'd be so sad.
Why?
Everybody loves the Fortnite.
Everybody loves the Fortnite bus.
We love Fortnite.
I'm gonna sit.
Everybody knows the backseat is the best seat.
I know, that's why I'm here.
Yeah, that's why I'm here too.
That's what...
That's your camera looking.
It is.
It's doing its best.
I'm doing its best, guys.
I'm trying.
That's all that matters.
You can tell that there's effort going in.
Alright, what world should we go next?
Let's see...
There's so many new things.
It's so hard to...
I know.
There's like...
Chat, where do you wanna go?
Chat, give us some suggestions.
What is the hippest new...
There's Omegle VR.
Yeah, no.
Stop.
I don't think that probably works.
Omegle VR.
Let's see.
Okay.
Where's some good places?
Let's see.
What's my favorite?
Oh, I only have Chickentopia.
Chickentopia!
I mean, it was a pretty good place.
It was.
Chickentopia.
Wait, I wanna see like the popular...
Oh, here we go.
Trending world.
Trending.
Yeah.
Umm...
We could go to Murder 4.
Murder 4?
More murdering?
Furry Hideout?
Oh my...
Oh my god, Doki, they're just in your head!
Like, give them something to see.
What about Lox ERP Room?
Lox ERP Room?
There's a hundred and... There's a hundred and twenty-eight people in there.
I don't think it's...
Wait, do you wanna play Uno?
Oh my god, there's Uno?
Oh my god.
There's Hazbin Hotel!
There's...
Oh my god, there's... There's Hazbin Hotel, man!
Oh my god, there's a Game Theory!
Wait, can we go?
Can we go?
Can we go to Luigi's Casino?
Wait, let's go!
Okay, Luigi's Casino, and then my next pick is Game Theory GT Live.
Okay, okay.
You save that one, and we'll go to it.
Yeah, I'm gonna save that one.
I'm adding that to the favorite.
Okay, favorite world one out of one.
Okay, I'm adding that to the favorite.
I'm dropping a portal.
Wait, the Fortnite bus?
Yeah, it's out... I think it's gonna be in the front of the...
Okay, hold on, I need to... Where's the Fortnite bus?
Where is it?
Wait, oh, oh, this way.
It's outside, it's outside!
Oh, okay.
Where did you drop the portal?
Right here.
Oh, there it is.
Here I go!
Oh my god, Luigi's Casino!
Yay!
Finally, Luigi's doing something!
Finally!
What the fuck?
Wait...
Oh my god, you're in... Whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Okay.
Level up the camera.
Oh no, we have no light gravity here.
No, wait, there's slots!
There's slots machine!
Where's Luigi?
Yeah, where's Luigi?
We were lied to!
I was promised Luigi!
Yeah!
I was promised Luigi in my Luigi Casino!
Okay.
Behind me.
Guys, we're gonna...
We're gonna make it.
Aw man!
Let's go!
Aw dang it!
Now I remember why I don't do my own cameras anymore.
Now I remember why.
I remember why I have camera men now.
I tried... Whoa!
I took a photo!
I accidentally took a photo.
What's happening?
I'm trying to... Where did it go?
Where did the camera go?
It's right... Hold on.
Okay, wait.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
It's right on your face.
It's right here.
Okay, I won't put it here.
And then...
Auto level.
World.
There we go.
Yay!
I figured it out!
Oh.
I didn't figure it out.
I figured it out!
I figured it out.
This place sucks.
Wait, they're in the table.
You gotta move.
Oh, there you go.
No, no, no.
There's slots right here!
What's wrong with it?
This place sucks, Doki.
Why?
Just get on the slot machine.
Let's go gambling!
Oh, that's it?
Wait, that's it?
That's it?
Where's Luigi?
We promised Luigi!
I don't know!
There's no Luigi!
We've been bamboozled for real!
We've been bamboozled!
Where's Luigi?
Why were there a hundred... Why is this a trending ad?
There's nothing here.
Do people just go, let's go gambling!
Is that it?
Is that what made it trending?
I know!
Let's go gambling!
Okay, let's go to the GT Live.
Let's go to the GT Live.
Let's do some game theory.
Alright, where are those?
Where's my...
Aw, dang it.
Who would I lie to?
Okay.
New instance.
Friend Plus.
There we go.
Oh my god, the portal thing is different too.
What?
Let's go gambling!
Aw, dang it.
Let's go... Aw, dang it.
Let's go gambling!
Aw, dang it.
Here we go.
I can't believe it!
We got lied to!
Where did our...
Where did our fucking Luigi go?
I was promised Luigi!
Wait.
Where's this?
Jacksepticeye?
In space with Markiplier?
We're on observa...
There's Observation Duty!
You love that game!
Observation...
Oh yeah!
Yeah, Observation Duty!
What is this?
There's Homestucks here!
Is this copyrighted?
Do you hear this?
Is this copyrighted music?
What is that?
I don't know.
It's alright, whatever.
Is it?
Yeah!
Whatever, what are you gonna do, take my ad money?
Oh!
What is this?
Oh my god, you guys don't see it!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Where did it go?
It's the camera!
I need you guys to see this!
It's right here!
Oh, okay.
All right.
What is this?
Oh, shit, look!
It's some song!
Yeah, we don't know what this is.
It says DokiBirdYoutube.com I think it's you.
Wait, what?
I think it's you.
Wait, it's me?
Oh my god!
This is what she watches every day, you guys!
Gosh, guys, why?
Oh, it's because I have Look At Me on!
There you go, guys!
Oh, um...
You're getting there.
You're almost there.
Oh, why is it...
Do auto-level.
Wait, I didn't know that's a thing!
There you go.
Yeah.
This is what we're watching.
Here, here.
You're so much better at this than me.
Holy shit.
There you go.
Who are...
Who are these people?
Are you actually listening to it?
Yeah.
Are you allowed to?
Oh, okay.
How creepers get to explode?
I'm like the hat in time gif.
It's just... Who is that?
Who is that guy?
Who is he?
He's pretty catchy.
I don't think I'm on full body.
There we go.
Dude, a monster!
A monster?
Woah!
I smacked...
I heard that.
Yeah, I smacked it.
He's a thriller.
Thriller.
Night.
I love the...
How long is this song?
This is a five minute song!
I don't think it's a movie.
No, it's a five minute!
Oh, you're right.
Hey, this is like game suggestions for us.
I feel so immersed right now.
I know.
Oh my gosh, guys, look.
We'll show you guys the rest of...
The rest of the place.
Yeah.
Okay.
Look!
This is where MatPat does his theories!
Look at that!
I'm turning off the music.
I can't do this anymore.
Guys!
They have a playlist?
Oh my god!
Doki Doki Decoded!
MatPat!
Maoshi!
Oh my god!
We're gonna figure out the game theory!
Just Monika!
Oh my god!
We can watch game theory!
Like a kid, you know, when it's damn too close.
A really rich kid with VR chat.
With VR.
No, I'm just like really close to the screen.
Oh my god!
MatPat!
Where's the intro?
Give me the game theory!
There it is!
Welcome to game theory!
So in part one of this theory, we start to unearth a horror game hidden underneath the I can't believe he's actually just going off.
Oh my god.
What is the theory?
...experiments and cults.
All topics that appear in Yuri's book Among Us.
This show happens to have a mysterious I am the Doki.
Let me...
...
What is this?
Just a theory.
It's a sand bird!
What's a golden freddy?
What's a golden freddy does?
It's probably he's here, he's there, he's everywhere.
Horror, horror, horror.
Okay, Kim, do it.
Wait, how do you press it?
How did you press that?
I think you have to be holding it.
Yeah, you have to be holding it first.
We should visit Freddy's Fazbear!
Did you take it?
No, where'd it go?
Where'd it go?
I think it went through the wall!
I think it was based in the wall!
No, not that!
How will we know if it's a game, Perry?
How?
Wait, it's on the floor!
Oh, where'd it go?
Where?
Oh, it's over there.
Okay, nice.
It was through the floor.
Okay, we should...
Do you like his house?
I feel a little uncomfortable.
No, this is his office.
Oh, there's bean bags!
There's a pool table?
There's a keypad?
Oh, wow, the cookers!
Whoa!
Doki, put on the mirror.
We're in the game theory.
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, I wanna know.
Wait, wait, I wanna...
Put on the mirror.
Oh my god, we're in the game!
Doki, put on the mirror!
Doki!
We're in the game theory.
This entire time, we were in the...
I probably look like a crazy person.
Wait, it doesn't show on the...
No!
It doesn't show on the camera!
It just looks like we're in the void!
We're in the game theory!
No, you don't understand!
We're in the game theory, look!
We're in the game theory!
It's the video, right there!
Which one's the real Doki?
I don't know.
Whoa, which one's the real Doki?
Ooh!
Oh no, they're converging!
They're converging!
Oh god, why do I look like that?
Oh my god, this is Mint's true form.
This is her true form.
You know like Angel's true form?
Biblically accurate Mint.
If I...
If we touch the finger, will we get sucked in?
Oh, oh.
I'm...
SCP's Mint, right there.
We should... we should visit FNAF!
We should visit FNAF!
I wanna...
You look scared to do it though.
No I won't, I'm not baby.
Is this like an official world?
There's like even...
Wait, yeah, I think so.
Wait, are we supposed to break... oh my god, is there an ARG in VRChat?
I think so.
Oh my god, there's like codes and stuff.
This is like a code.
Guys, can you guys do this for us?
We're gonna go to FNAF world.
You figure it out.
Guys, Dragoons and Wisp work together and figure out how to break... how to solve MatPat's codes.
Wait, did they see it?
Hold on, hold on.
Here, here, here.
I'll show it to them.
Oh wait, there's a back, there's a front.
Here's the front.
Yeah, yeah.
Here's the front everybody.
And then there's a back.
That's the front.
Yeah.
You got it?
Here's the back.
There it is.
Screenshot it?
Screenshot it.
Yep.
There that is.
Figure it out.
And then...
But hey, that's just a matter.
But Henry...
Welcome to Game Theory.
What?
Wait.
There's a...
Whoa!
That's a...
There's two fronts.
Yeah.
There's big fronts.
There's foot fronts.
Oh my god.
Wait guys.
Wait, wait.
There's a coat on the ceiling.
Okay, there's a coat on the ceiling.
What?
Where's the camera?
Oh my god, there is.
You guys don't see it.
We're not giving you hints on how to solve this puzzle.
You gotta go there yourself.
No hints for you.
Wait, but we'll show you the feet.
Wait, where's the mirror?
Wait, can I...
Can we show them the feet again?
What feet?
The feet on the ground.
Right here.
Feet.
Do you guys see it?
It's like right here.
Wait, it's on the wall?
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's on the wall.
What are they doing?
You didn't notice the wall?
It goes all the way up and then it goes to the code.
Oh.
That's some big ass feet.
Third eye.
What is this third eye shit?
Alright, take us to FNAF.
Are we really?
Yeah.
Wait, oh my god.
This is just straight up OBS right here.
Yeah, this is editing software.
Oh, this is how they do it.
This is how they do the GT Live.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's GT Live.
Oh, you're on the couch.
Oh my god, guys.
She's on the couch.
Wait, let me bring it to me.
Oh, here's the decoder.
Where's my camera?
Oh, there it is.
Guys, look.
In front of your face?
Yeah.
Guys, look.
There she is.
Wait.
Take a nap.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, real quick.
I'mve got to sit down.n I'm sitting down.
And set it down.
There's the camera right there.
Look and then the couch is like, where is it?
The couch is right there.
Its a little casting couch.
Yeah.
Which GT Live.
I think the camera is in your head.
You've got to put it far further away, I think.
Put it where my hand is.
Put it where your hand is.
Yeah, because when you move, for one sec...
All four Forward it covers it.
And then I'll do this.
And then... but then that's my face.
Yes.
No, turn it around.
Turn it...
Put it further from your face.
And then...
And then I do...
And then what do I do?
What do I do after that?
I don't know.
Aww, you're tight.
You're tight.
You're E.P.?
You want to end it on FNAF?
Yeah, I'm kind of...
Yeah, we can end it on FNAF.
Yeah, let's end it.
We'll do our announcement in FNAF.
Okay.
Five...
Five nights at Freddy's.
Nights...
I gotta find a good one.
Oh, that's true.
The most popular five nights at Freddy's.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm submitting.
Sorry, camera's in her head.
We're still figuring it out.
Eventually I'll learn how to...
Wait, there's like... nobody goes to these ones.
What?
Is FNAF dead?
Oh, wait.
Wait, this one has 13 people.
Maybe it's popular.
Oh my god.
That one instance with 13 people.
Is FNAF dead, guys?
We can go to...
This one.
This one looks legit.
I think.
Okay, I'm gonna put in an instance.
I'm just gonna sit down.
Oh my god.
We sit.
Alright, I'm dropping the portal.
Right here.
Oh, oh god.
This is a prank.
Oh, we have 19 seconds to go through that.
Oh, okay.
Let's go.
Yay!
We're gonna announce something FNAF!
Woo!
FNAF!
It's time.
Yeah, so people don't like run...
People we don't want can run into the portal.
Whoa!
Oh.
Man.
This is spooky.
This one's scary.
This is scary.
Yeah, man.
I thought you said it would be funny.
Why is the light?
Why is it scary?
Why is it so scary?
Oh my god.
We can be friends.
What's that?
Oh, I turned out the light.
Oh.
What if the battery runs out?
I don't...
Where is it?
Is there no lights?
I don't know.
I don't like this.
Oh.
Oh my god.
You're making me scared.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Is this shit?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I was like, no one's in there before.
Where did that come from?
Oh my god.
I scared the shit out of me.
I'm so scared.
Where did you go?
Man.
Where did...
Where did she go?
Where?
I'm at FNAF 2?
How did you get to FNAF...
How did you get there?
Oh my god.
Where is it?
How did you get to FNAF 2?
It's just FNAF.
She's at...
Wait.
She left my instance.
What?
What do you mean she left my instance?
Oh my god.
The camera is so short when I'm fucking crooky.
Holy shit.
Wait.
Where did I go?
Oh.
There I am.
She left my instance.
She deced.
She must have deced.
Okay.
I'm gonna check if she's...
Let's explore a little bit then.
Clearly it's not that scary, right?
Oh.
There's legs.
There I am.
Hey.
That's where people do that.
Oh.
There's my camera.
I go see it off FNAF.
I don't wanna see it off FNAF anymore.
I don't know if I wanna see the FNAF anymore.
Oh.
Is this FNAF 2?
I'm downloading new stuff.
What is it?
Udon tycoon?
Why are you...
What did she take me?
She took me to udon tycoon.
Are we playing tycoon?
I'm connecting.
What the fuck is udon tycoon?
Oh.
Hey.
Are you doing hot spring?
Are we doing announcement about the hot spring?
Sure.
I just picked a random place.
Because I got sent to FNAF 2 and I was scared.
How did you get to FNAF 2?
Wait.
Let me fix the camera.
I don't know.
I pressed the button and I was looking up to FNAF.
We didn't get to explore FNAF.
Okay.
It's okay.
It was very scary.
Do you wanna go back?
It was pretty scary.
I don't know.
We're at like udon world.
Yeah.
I was like why is she at udon tycoon?
Oh my god.
I'm too short.
I wish you could let other people control the camera.
Because I'm too short.
No.
What are you doing?
I'm trying to...
Change back.
We'll announce as Freddy and...
and...
We'll announce as...
I fell back.
We'll announce as Kroki and...
and Freddy.
As the hot springs.
The crossover of the century guys.
Wow.
Yeah.
The crossover of the century.
Alright.
So.
Because Min has another stream later on.
So we gotta make this quick.
How much more do you have time to set up?
Oh.
Not a lot.
Okay.
So.
Alright.
Now it's Min.
I won't be on the stream though.
But after.
So.
But Min's gonna go prep.
And we're just gonna chill.
After that.
Me and the dragoons.
But.
The announcement.
Is that.
So.
You guys know.
That I'll be going to...
Annie Revolution.
Um.
In Canada.
And.
The thing is.
I will be doing.
A karaoke concert there.
And there is...
Around 2000 seats there.
And I invited...
Min to be a guest at my concert.
Yeah.
She's gonna be singing there too.
Hoor.
For those who can't make it though.
We will post something.
We will post something a little special after the concert.
Um.
For those who get.
Who has FOMO for it.
We will have a little bit something special posted.
Um.
That Min and I are working on.
So.
So don't worry.
You guys can get to the concert.
We will post something special.
That's gonna be uploaded after.
Yeah.
So get your tickets.
Um.
The concert tickets aren't out yet.
But get your tickets for the convention.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Details will be out soon.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha ha.
Alright.
So yeah.
That's the announcement.
Are you excited?
I'm so excited.
Yeah.
Have you decided your set list?
Have you decided your set list yet?
Uh.
Yes.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh my god.
We've decided our duet set list already.
So like.
Don't worry about that guys.
Shh.
It's a little secret.
You guys are gonna like it.
It's a secret.
Oh.
You should sing the Freddy Fazbear Tombstone song.
Wait.
What is that?
You know like.
FNAF has a song from The Tombstones.
Oh.
It does?
Yeah.
I don't remember how it goes but.
The Tombstones.
But it was super popular.
I'm Freddy Fazbear.
And I like to hug and share.
I will give you a hug.
And I'll squish you like a bug.
The only tombstone I know is discord.
Discord!
That's from My Little Pony.
I'm enjoying the hot spring.
I'm at what?
What's the difference?
Well, are you?
Well, you knew the song!
You knew the Discord song!
What does that make you?
Can I get...
Can I get into the hot springs too?
Yeah, come on in.
How does it look?
What?
It looks like you're about to fucking die.
Someone's like, sing FNAF at the concert.
Sing FNAF at the concert!
Like, we'll just be there and be like, Har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har And then you know like, in the video there's like the lyrics on the screen and it's just har har har har har har har har har We could do it.
I'm doing it while doing backflips.
Oh my god, the best part was they were like, you can pick any song too for the concert.
You don't have to worry about permissions and stuff because we can sing anything.
We could just be like, har har har har har har har har har har har har har That's a classic song!
I know!
That would be like the...
That's royalty free!
That would be like the most expensive shitpost we've ever done.
That would be really good.
Two thousand people like waving their pen lights and be like, har har har har har har And the Freddy Fazbear light colors.
And together everybody!
har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har
Oh my god.
Yeah we should do it!
We should do it!
We're gonna leak one song from the setlist.
We will sing a Freddy Faz...
We're singing a FNAF song.
No, it has to be that one.
Yeah, yeah.
What?
I have a mic.
What do you mean?
Oh, you're Freddy Fazbear!
I'm really Freddy Fazbear!
Wait, where'd it go?
Where'd it go?
I don't know.
Oh, it's like hand gesture, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, it seems like a hand gesture thing.
The crossover of the century.
Crow and...Croaky and Freddy Fazbear.
And Freddy Fazbear.
That's me.
I'll be there.
Is this your tickets to meet me, Freddy Fazbear?
Yeah, meet Golden Freddy.
You can meet...
You can meet Golden Freddy in Canada!
I'm going to Canada!
Oh my god!
He's going to Canada!
What are you doing?
Hold on.
Is that the bite of 87?
One second.
Wait.
I'm...I'm...I'm...
I'm Freddy-ing it up right now.
You're Freddy-ing it up?
Are you figuring out your hand gestures?
Yeah, I'm Freddy-ing it up.
Oh my god.
She's going to Freddy it up.
I'm going to Freddy it up.
She's going to do it.
Wait, where did she go?
Oh my god.
It's a frog.
What's your name, sir?
Can you say that again?
Can you repeat that?
Please, I'm crazy.
Please tell yourself that you're always wanting to go to Canada.
Oh my god!
Frogbert!
Hello!
How do you feel about going to Canada, Frogbert?
Yeah, I'm going to go there.
I'm going to really soak it all in.
Oh my god.
You're going to see the tropical rainforest in Canada?
Oh yeah.
I'm excited.
I've got my sparklers ready for all the excitement I'm going to have.
Oh my god.
Is Frogbert going to sing?
I'll sing if Akroki will sing.
You'll have to see it find out.
You'll have to come to the concert to find out.
If someone is making their first Canadian debut.
Woo!
You guys hear that?
You guys got to go to Canada.
I'm going to see your Oshie Frogbert doing a funky little dance.
Frogbert, do a little dance for us.
To show your excitement.
Oh my god.
He's feeling himself.
Look at him.
He's touching himself right now.
Oh my god.
Spank that butt.
He's like guys don't miss out.
Don't miss out.
Yeah!
Say goodbye to Frogbert.
Say goodbye to...
Oh my god.
We're getting everybody's Oshies today.
Okay.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
Oh my god.
You missed out.
You missed Frogbert.
Oh he was here?
Yeah.
Good thing I wasn't then.
You missed out.
I know.
I think I'm good.
I think that guy is a menace.
Oh my god.
He was like...
He shook his ass for us.
He like gave us a little smack too.
Like poof.
Like that.
It was crazy.
Wait but Frogbert's going to be in Canada too.
Are you guys going to cross paths?
Oh maybe.
If he does, I'm going to have my shank ready.
Oh.
That's scary.
Yeah Frogbert watch out.
She's got her shank.
Watch out.
Alright.
Thank you.
I'm on to you Froggy boy.
Thank you to Mint for coming here.
For this not so special day.
It's just a normal day.
Yeah.
For a little announcement together.
I had so much fun.
Come to the convention.
Come to Canada.
Come to Con... Oh shit.
More details will be out soon regarding the concert everybody.
So look forward to it guys.
I'm so excited to see you all there.
Dragoons and Wisp and everybody else.
Frogbert and Oshie.
What are Frogbert's fans called?
Tadpoos?
Oh I don't know.
Tadbird?
Tadpoos.
The Tadbirds.
Oh Pyromaniac.
I don't know.
We'll have to...
Maybe if Frogbert makes like a Vtuber debut he can come up with something.
True.
It's not your job.
He's got his own business going on.
Yeah exactly.
That's not your job.
He has to do it himself.
I'm too busy you guys.
Yeah we're all too busy.
Too much on my plate.
Yeah yeah yeah.
But we hope you see Frogbert fans and Croaky fans as well.
And FNAF fans.
For those who want to hear us sing FNAF.
Oh god.
Are we actually doing this?
Yeah of course!
We hyped it up!
Okay guys I need a video recording of that.
I will retweet the video recording of that if somebody records it.
I just want to see the pen lights going har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har har
I'll better.
You guys.
Yeah?
We got to see it.
I better see a fnaf cosplayer there in audience too.
oh no wait who's your What's your character though?
oh it's so hard to choose...
there's Foxy, there's Chica, that's true Chica.
You want a Spicy Chica.
That's what she wants.
Oooh..then what's your favourite?
Chica with a
Someone's been looking at the wrong Chica file.
Probably Foxy.
I like Foxy.
You got that fox in ya.
That's a little dangerous.
He has the little hook hands too.
Yeah.
Okay, I gotta go doki.
You gotta set up for your thing.
I'll see you later.
Bye!
Thanks for coming!
Bye guys!
I'll still be here.
I'm gonna still be here.
Bye, Mint!
Good luck with your stream!
I'll rate it later.
When I'm done.
Bye!
Bye bye!
Yay!
Oh, she's still here.
Bye!
That was fun!
Okay, let me get a little closer.
Whoa.
That was fun, guys!
I had a lot of fun.
I want you all to hang out here.
Just chill a little bit.
Um, but huge shout out.
Huge thank you again to Mint for dropping by.
Um, and like hanging out with me.
I didn't really have anything.
I said it's not a special day or anything.
So I had like not anything planned.
I just wanted to hang out.
But like I had to stream today.
So I thought it was a... I really appreciate Mint for dropping by.
I literally was like, hey, um...
I have no plans.
Do you want to do like...
VR chat stuff together?
And then we can use it to announce our concert together.
So she was like, yeah, we can do it.
Like, um, after she was like, oh, you want me to...
I can cancel my stream.
I was like, no, no, no, no.
Don't cancel.
We can do it like before your stream or after your stream.
And then, um, we were like, oh, we'll just do a little short thing and just announce it.
And then like you do your stream.
Your stream is more important because like the WIS want to watch.
Um, you know, it's a solo stream.
The WIS won't watch you.
Um, but I really appreciate it because like, you know, she was like, oh, no, it's okay.
I can, I can like, I can like drop by for a bit before the stream and everything.
And it was really sweet.
I was like, oh, you won big time.
Because like, you know, she, I like found out last...
I was like, I was like, oh my god, I need to, I need to, uh, I need to do this announcement.
I was like, I was like, I figured out I had to do something today.
So I was like, oh my gosh, okay, what do I do on this normal day?
Because I figured like you guys would want me to stream something today.
Um, but I've been enjoying my break and everything.
Just like, relaxing and chilling in the hot springs.
Um, I've just been like, mostly just chilling, I guess.
Like, I've been sleeping a lot.
And I don't have a schedule out yet because I don't, I don't, I don't know what to do this week.
I've just been like relaxing.
It's actually been really nice.
I've been touching grass.
I went to the dog park today.
Oh, not today.
Sorry.
Yesterday.
I went to the dog park yesterday and I brought, uh, dad over.
And just like, um, dad met a lot of like, oh it was so funny because uh, when I brought dad over to the dog park, it was like his first time at this particular dog park.
And like, we accident- like, uh, we brought like this giant ass tennis ball that was way too big for his head.
And like he was just carrying around like, He was just carrying around the tennis ball, just walking around and was like, this is my ball.
And then every dog that comes over trying to like play with him, he's like, NO!
This is MY ball!
It was really fun.
Um, I've been touching grass and just like relaxing and stuff.
So, it's been nice.
It's been nice.
That's why I haven't had a schedule yet because I've been like, low- I've just been like um, just relaxing.
I was like, I was like, oh no the dragoons, I feel like the dragoons were going to want me to stream today.
And I was like, what do I do?
What do I do?
I haven't been paying attention.
I mean, of what?
Because this is a normal day.
Um, but like-
Um, but yeah, I don't know when my schedule is going to be out yet.
Um, I've also been working on like a lot of things behind the scenes and everything.
And, um, just been busy.
Been busy.
I know it's like counter- like I feel like I'm counter-talking myself because I was like, oh, I'm busy, but also but also, I've been busy, but also relaxing at the same time.
Um...
Oh, what a surprise!
Oh!
It's been, uh...
It's been a lot.
It's been a lot of work, but it's nice.
Not streaming for the last couple of days.
Um, I don't know.
I'm going to be streaming tomorrow.
I might do a member stream tomorrow.
Um...
I don't know.
There ain't nothing in my head!
I have nothing in my head at the moment.
I've just been like...
fucking dead.
I have nothing in my head.
I've just been like...
like... not there.
Um...
No thoughts.
Yeah.
Just no thoughts.
That's why I tweeted.
I was like, what do I do this week?
I don't really...
I didn't want to play any video games.
I just wanted to like...
do something non-gaming related.
Um...
But yeah, no thoughts.
Head empty.
Yeah, just no thoughts.
But thank you everybody for coming!
I had like a...
I'm just going to check the time.
Oh, we have plenty of time.
We have plenty of time.
Let me see if there's any worlds I want to visit while we're here.
I need to blow my nose.
Give me a sec.
I need to hydrate.
I haven't even drank any water.
Let me drink the hot spring water.
No way!
That's unhealth hygienic.
Um... Give me a sec.
I'm going to mute myself and blow my nose and drink...
drink hydrate because I haven't hydrated at all.
I think you guys can hear from my voice.
Give me a sec.
Oh... Where's the mouse?
I need to mute myself.
Alright.
I'm back.
Okay.
I'm back guys.
But yeah!
It's been...
Um... I've been having a nice, just relaxing day and uh...
I'm really excited.
When they told me I'm doing a concert for Anime Revolution.
Anime Revolution.
Um... I was like...
What?
You know it was like... It was one of those moments where I like said yes to everything when it came to conventions.
So I didn't realize what I said yes to.
So like they were like... It's going to be an hour long concert.
Um...
And like it seats like 2000 people.
I was like... What?
I was like...
Wait... I said yes to this?
I signed the contract for this?
What?
Oh my gosh.
I don't remember.
And then um...
So I was like...
I was not expecting it.
And I was not...
I was not paying attention at all.
And uh...
And then so then I was just like... Oh no.
I don't know if I want to sing for like an hour by myself.
So I asked like if Mint... Because I know Mint really loves doing concerts and everything.
And that she enjoys like you know singing to everybody.
I was like... Mint do you wanna uh... do you wanna...
uh... you know...
uh... sing like...
uh... you wanna sing in this concert?
Um... I can give you like half the...
like... like give you half the program if you want.
Um...
Yeah so...
uh... yeah she's really good at concerts so I invited her as a guest and be like you wanna sing?
Because like you know I have... you know we should concert and you know you're...
you love concerts.
Yeah so...
I'm really excited and for those who can't make it who can't make it to the convention and the concert um... we will have like something special that's gonna be uploaded after the concert for those who can't make it.
I mean it won't be like you know it won't be like the full set list of like you know we won't have like the whole recording of the concert being uploaded or anything but it will be something special um... that we made for people who can't make it.
Um...
to be able to like you know also have a fun time and also enjoy themselves even though like they're not there.
They could get... because you know traveling and hotels accommodations is very expensive.
So Mint and I we will upload something I think like on my channel.
Um...
Uh... something special Uh... for you guys who won't be there.
So yeah!
Hor hor hor hor hor hor hor hor hor hor hor I can't wait.
That's the only song that we're leaking for you guys.
That's gonna be in the set list.
Hor hor hor hor hor hor hor hor I don't think Anime Revolution has like streaming tickets set up.
Like...
I think that's like... I don't think they've ever done streaming tickets before.
I know like that's so much to set up in general cause like you have to make a deal with like these streaming set up streaming places like streaming platforms for like tickets and stuff.
That's a lot to set up.
So...
Like... that's like...
I feel like that's like not in time to to set something up like that.
...
Um...
Also like with the song choices that we have cause like we can pick any songs too.
...
We can pick any songs too.
So like I don't think like rights in general like legal rights for like song picks would work if we stream it.
Cause we could literally pick anything we want to sing.
...
Um...
Yeah, we can pick any song.
They were like, don't worry about what songs you want to sing.
You can pick anything you want.
And I'm like, nice.
Nice.
This was before Mint got invited as a guest.
So I was like, nice.
She'll only be a guest at the concert portion.
So the other stuff like the panels and the meet and greets and stuff like that is just me.
But she'll be there for the concert for those who are wondering.
Like for any WISPs that are coming over to see if there's like meet and greets for Mint or like panel or anything.
It's just me for the rest.
But she'll be there for the concert.
I want to go to another world.
It's been nice chilling in the hot spring.
I want to go somewhere new.
I want to stream until Mint goes live and they'll raid her.
How many more minutes?
15 minutes.
Alright, let's relax.
Bye bye.
Let's see.
Search words.
I hope the volume was okay.
I saw like my sound guy was like, turn down, turn it down, turn it down.
I don't know if I turned it down enough.
I don't know.
I turned down so many things.
I don't know if I turned it enough.
I hope the volume was fine.
Mint moved her stream.
She goes live in 45...
Okay.
Well, I'm not staying in VR for 45 minutes.
I'll just... I'll raid into her waiting room.
Sorry guys.
I love Mint but I'm not fucking streaming 45 more minutes of VR.
I need it.
I would take this off.
Alright.
Boop.
Drop order.
I want a cake.
You know what's worse?
Something else.
To celebrate this normal day.
Happy birthday!
Whose birthday is it?
Is it anybody's birthday?
Okay.
Wait.
Let me make sure it's local.
And then... look at me.
I'm so bad at this.
Like... I'm so bad at the cam...
I don't know how Mint does this.
I... I'm so bad at the camera.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for my poor camera work, everybody.
I'm trying my best.
I'm sorry.
Whose birthday is it?
Is it today?
Is it anybody's birthday?
Wait.
I thought this would have a thing where we can...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Can I not blow the candle though?
Oh I can!
Wait.
How do I blow it?
Okay.
You guys can't see that.
Maybe this is not the best world.
Maybe.
I'm gonna sit down.
I've been standing up a long time.
Woo!
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Worlds.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear dragons.
Yay!
Birthday!
Is there anyone where you can like pick up the cake and be like...
That would be so cool.
I wonder if they actually have that function.
That would be so cute if they did.
Oh my gosh.
Let's go to the bar!
Wait.
Actually no.
Let's not.
Some of you guys might not be legal enough to go to the bar.
I don't wanna get in trouble.
I don't wanna get in trouble with the police.
Okay.
Let's go to the air.
Maybe the air?
Friend plus.
Join.
Some of you guys are not...
Different countries have different drinking laws.
I don't wanna get in trouble with the law.
I don't wanna get in trouble with the cops.
Hahahaha.
Woah.
Whoa!
Where the fuck is the cake?
How's your...
Woah!
Where's the cake?
There's the cake, guys!
There it is!
Happy birthday!
Okay.
Let me... I got this.
Wait.
I don't got this.
Okay, and then we do loco and then word and then...
Yay!
God, please please happy birthday.
Oh my god, please give me a give me a sec.
I'm a professional
It's June's birthday dragons!
Happy birthday!
Yeah!
Here you go.
And don't worry.
I got you guys.
I got you guys some cups some some champagne some no alcohol champagne Come on!
Oh shit dropped it!
Whoa, wait, sorry.
I don't know how Mint does this.
I don't know how she does VR chats so often.
Maybe if I do more VR chats I can do this better.
Guys!
Happy birthday!
To another year of this normal day!
Clink!
Oh, sorry, I clinked the camera.
Don't worry!
It's sparkling water!
That's the fizzy part!
It's the sparkling water!
Clink!
Cheers!
To another year of this normal day!
To another year of this normal, normal-ass day!
You know what?
I feel a little generous today.
I was like, what else can I announce today?
I can say that officially by this week I'm currently working on a 3D modeler.
Yeah!
Who specializes?
A 3D modeler.
I won't reveal who it is.
But I'm currently working on a 3D modeler that has done motion capture models for Hololive.
Yeah!
Clink!
So I'm excited!
It's going to be a while though.
What a big announcement on Sunday.
Such a normal day.
Yay!
I'm really happy.
I'm so happy.
There's so many good things coming.
And I'm really happy to spend it.
Spend another year with you dragons.
And um...
And...
Have so much fun!
Every day.
Well almost every day.
Because I was AFK for three days.
But almost every day!
It's been a wild ride.
Um... and...
I hope things calm down soon.
Not gonna lie.
I hope...
I hope things calm down soon.
Because I need...
So many wild things.
Maybe a little bit too many wild things.
Cheers!
Cheers everybody!
Clink!
It's been a wild year.
2024.
It's been pretty wild.
I love my sparkling water.
Um...
I've been having a great time Spending it with you dragons.
And I hope...
we go for another year.
Let me grab your Oishi real fast.
Let me grab your actual Oishi.
Hey guys, so you've only met me like, uh, you've only met me for like maybe like a couple of months, but
But what amazing couple of months guys
Can't believe it.
I finally met Frogbert.
Oh my god Frogbert and croaky.
What a duo I'll try to convince Frogbert to also appear in the concert guys.
I'll try Maybe you'll see me too everyone But it's been it's been wild I'm gonna cut it here.
So but thank you everybody for coming as always everybody Stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me Me specifically croaky head to bed cuz you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody Bye guys.
Whoa, I need a spin
Don't mind my neck
Where is it?
Sorry, I can't find the ending screen.
Give me a sec Where is it?
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Bye